now when we did these calculation we saw
that the kinetic energy in the ground
frame was equal to the kinetic energy in
the center-of-mass frame plus a constant
term m1 plus m2 times V cm squared and
this is a constant whether you're in the
initial or the final picture so if we
look at the change in kinetic energy in
the ground frame that's equal to the
change in kinetic energy in the
center-of-mass frame but this term is a
constant so there's no change in that
term and so we have a crucial result
that the change in kinetic energy in the
ground frame is equal to the change in
kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame now let's look at an example of a
collision that's completely elastic
inelastic so we have object 1 and it's
coming in with v1 initial an object -
let's make it at rest and afterwards
object 1 and 2 stick together and they
go off with the final so here's a
collision in the an inelastic frame now
in the center-of-mass frame the two
objects so here's our lab or a ground
frame I can call it the lab frame
because that one's at rest and this is
the CM frame and there we have v1 Prime
and v2 Prime they're both moving and now
in the center-of-mass frame they're at
rest at the end of the collision so in
this collision we can analyze it and now
what I want to show is that the change
in kinetic energy recall from our
previous calculation that the kinetic
energy in the center-of-mass frame was
equal to one-half mu times the relative
velocity squared so remember v12 was
equal to v1 minus v2 and so the change
in kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame is the final kinetic energy 0
minus 1/2 the kinetic energy in the
initial state and what is this quantity
initial well this was a reference frame
independent concept so we can just look
at the lab frame and write this as v1
initial I had where that's I hat because
this object is at rest and so right away
we have that the change in kinetic
energy is minus 1/2 now remember meu was
m1 m2 over m1 plus m2 times v1 initial
squared and that's the same change in
kinetic energy as the ground frame so by
using our result here and our result
there we were able to very quickly
assess how much kinetic energy is lost
in this inelastic collision and where
does that kinetic energy go it can go to
a variety of places deformation of
objects it can go into sound it can go
into thermal energy that gets rear aided
that is transmitted into the environment
through diffuses into the environment
however that's how much is changed